bonjour à tous donc je suis alexandre
luneau un ancien joueur de poker
professionnel et je
près d'une dizaine d'années mais tout
d'abord avant d'aller plus loin je vais
essayer de clarifier ce qu'est le poker
pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont pas
forcément familier avec ce jeu et aussi
parce que c'est un univers où il ya
beaucoup de clichés autour qui sont
véhiculées par les médias qui sont pas
toujours vrai donc le poker est un jeu
de stratégie et de hasard et si la part
de hasard est relativement importante
sur le court terme
le meilleur joueur en prenant de
meilleures décisions que l'adversaire va
gagner sur le long terme et les
informations qu un joueur de poker à
prendre pour faire ces décisions voix de
différentes natures
ça peut être basé sur l'historique de la
partie la psychologie les mathématiques
la logique ou même le langage corporel
ou la théorie des jeux et c'est
véritablement un flux d'information le
joueur de poker va devoir gérer pour
prendre la meilleure décision possible
le monde dans lequel moi j'ai volé
principalement au cours de ma carrière
et le monde du poker sur internet et sam
ont assez particulier qui est au final
un peu différent du monde du poker tels
qu'ils peuvent jouer dans les casinos
est l'une des différences principales et
le temps disponible pour prendre les
décisions
typiquement sur internet on avoir entre
5 et 10 secondes pour chaque décision ce
qui est un temps relativement court
de par le volume d'informations
disponibles particulièrement au niveau
pour prendre la meilleure décision
possible les parties que moi j'ai joué
plus particulièrement du moins durant ma
carrière était là où les enchères
étaient les plus élevés ces partis
avaient d'ailleurs un surnom on les
appelait les noces blé l'idée derrière
ce nom était que la violence mentale de
ces partis étaient si fortes qu'elles
pourraient théoriquement vous en faire
saigner du nez et pour vous dire vous
donner un ordre d'idée il était possible
de gagner ou de perdre dans ces parties
plusieurs centaines de milliers dollars
par jour voire même parfois sur une
décision donc cet environnement dénonce
bleed avait énormément de pression une
pression de par le volume d'informations
disponibles avec une pression par 2 par
la contrainte temporelle mais également
la pression au niveau des enjeux car le
joueur de poker joué son propre argent
donc je vais essayer maintenant de vous
donner les points clés selon moi à
travers l'exemple du poker
qui m'ont permis à moi et à d'autres
joueurs de haut niveau de réussir à
gérer cette pression a performé dans cet
environnement des parties de noces bid
dont l'un des premiers points et la
préparation donc c'est quelque chose je
suis sûr vous êtes assez familier avec
mais que néanmoins beaucoup de gens
sous-estiment en effet va vraiment
falloir faire du mieux que vous pouvez
pas arriver avec un handicap dans un
environnement qui va être compétitif et
difficile à gérer
il va falloir arriver avec un esprit
sain et en corse un parcours saint
j'entends des choses aussi simples que
faire du sport régulièrement de revient
le bon nombre d'heures manger sainement
ces choses là vont vraiment vous aider à
gérer le stress et des swings émotionnel
que vous pouvez rencontrer lors de votre
activité où la pression est élevée
il faut aussi arriver avec un esprit
sain c'est à dire il faut pas arriver
avec de la négativité ou des émotions
négatives au poker c'est très frappant
car beaucoup de joueurs arrivés à lattes
avec de la colère
la raison étant que de par la présence
de hasard relativement importante sur le
court terme au poker il était possible
pour un joueur gagnant d'enchaîner
plusieurs journées perdante de suite
pour même plusieurs semaines voire même
des fois plusieurs mois perdent en
hausse 8 est la conséquence de sa sur le
mental était vraiment très importante
certains joueurs ressentaient de la
colère la frustration et un sentiment
d'injustice et cela l'est clairement se
mettre en travers de la qualité de leurs
décisions lorsqu'il arrive à la table et
étant donné que pour un joueur
professionnel sur une carrière il était
statistiquement extrêmement probable de
rencontrer une période de malchance ou
la liant à perdre plusieurs mois de
suite il était primordial pour les
joueurs de niveau d'arriver à gérer cet
aspect là et ce fut d'ailleurs un des
filtres les plus importants qui a
empêché des joueurs très talentueux ne
pas réussir au plus haut niveau au poker
car il arrivé avec trop d'émotions
négatives aux tables un autre élément
relativement important va être
l'abstraction
elle va se faire à différents niveaux
tout d'abord au niveau des enjeux dans
ces parties de poker comme je l'évoquais
les zones les enchères est extrêmement
élevé et le moment où on commençait à
réaliser qu'on prenne une décision pour
l'équivalent d'une voiture ou d'une
maison cela allait forcément impacter la
qualité nos décisions et il était
primordial d'arriver à visualiser les
sommes jouées comme une sorte de monnaie
virtuelle comme un score on voudrait
maximiser dans un jeu vidéo
l'abstraction elle va aussi se fait au
niveau des émotions donc comme j'ai pu
un peu plus l'évoquer à travers la
préparation vous voulez éviter d'avoir
des émotions négatives
néanmoins des fois elles vont survenir
et vous avez peu de contrôle dessus et
un point relativement fort que j'ai
compris dans ma carrière de poker et de
d'autres joueurs de haut niveau ont
aussi vu et que si vous vous efforcez de
faire abstraction de vos émotions
positives
lorsque vous prenez une bonne décision
pour des foires ressentir de la joie et
l'euphorie
si vous efforcez faire abstraction de ça
ça va être beaucoup plus facile de
rester dans un état émotionnel neutre
quand les choses se passent moins bien
et vous avez passé au final beaucoup
plus de temps dans un état émotionnel
neutre et mieux performer
l'instruction avait aussi se fait au
niveau de langage corporel j'entends
souvent l'idée que à travers langage
corporel il est possible d'extérioriser
de la frustration de la colère mais si
c'est peut-être vrai sur le long terme
de mon expérience sur le court terme
la conséquence directe de taper du poing
sur la table de soupirer sais que ça va
nourrir votre colère et vous faire
entrer dans une spirale négative et
voulait vraiment éviter ça il faut
vraiment garder en tête il ya un lien
assez fort entre votre langage chant
choral est votre état mental du moment
et vous devez faire du mieux que vous
pouvez pour garder un langage corporel
associée à la performance et au travail
l'instruction elle va aussi se fait au
niveau des choses sur lesquelles vous
n'avez pas de contrôle dans chaque
milieu savez différents pour le poker
les choses sur lesquelles on n'avait pas
contrôler qui était tout le temps
présent étaient les résultats à court
terme en effet quand je prenne une
décision
il y avait une corrélation extrêmement
faibles entre la qualité de ma décision
est le résultat qui s'ensuivait cinq
secondes plus tard est néanmoins en tant
qu'être humain c'est évidemment
extrêmement tentant de vouloir regarder
le résultat
suite à notre décision et pourtant il
était primordial de ne pas le regarder
car le moment on le faisait on attaché
de l'importance à sa salle et nous
affecter émotionnellement et ça nous
laissait moins de temps pour nous
concentrer sur les éléments sur lequel
on a du contrôle et dont on n'a même pas
tant de temps que ça disponibles pour
prendre en compte
vous voyez au final à travers la
préparation et l'abstraction
ce que j'essaie de faire dans ma
carrière c'est vraiment me donner les
meilleures chances d'avoir un niveau de
concentration très élevée car c'est
vraiment à travers une reconcentration
qu'on peut le mieux le mieux performé je
pense néanmoins nous sommes tous des
êtres humains et
aussi bon confie c'est dans des
capacités de concentration nous n'allons
jamais passé 100 % de notre temps dans
un état concentrations très élevées mais
normand c'est possible d'améliorer sa
une des idées assez important n'avait
été donnée il ya quelques années par un
coach mental
pierre gauthier qui a coaché de nombreux
sportifs de haut niveau et joueur de
poker et sa vision était la suivante
d'une il est important de réaliser que
lorsque vous n'êtes plus concentrés et
vous êtes conscient de ça si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez repasser
instantanément dans un état de
concentration
néanmoins tout le challenge est
d'arriver à repérer le moment où vous
n'êtes plus concentrés car par
définition c'est à dire d'avoir une
gouvernance de ce moment là
néanmoins ce même possible d'arriver à
repérer cependant peut-être
instantanément mais vous pouvez en ayant
conscience qu'il est important de
repérer quand vous n'êtes plus concentré
c'est possible d'arriver à repérer ces
moments là et si aujourd'hui en moyenne
ou pas c'est peut-être dans un
environnement que j'ai c'est de
performer dix minutes par heure non
concentré en arrivant à repérer le
moment vous n'êtes plus concentrés et
repasser dans un état de concentration
cela peut réduire ces dix minutes à
peut-être trois minutes moyenne en
passer par heure dans un état de non
concentration et cela une claire
conséquence un impact sur la qualité de
votre consommation globale et votre
performance
ça fait maintenant plus de six mois que
j'ai pris ma retraite du poker et
souvent on me pose pas mal de questions
de par ma carrière assez original et
l'une d'entre elles est de savoir
quelles sont les capacités les plus
intéressantes que j'ai pu tirer ma
carrière est souvent ma réponse c'est un
peu ce que j'ai essayé de vous expliquer
aujourd'hui à savoir avoir développé des
compétences nous permettent de mieux
gérer la pression dans des
environnements difficiles et ce qui vaut
d'ailleurs me sers de mon activité
activités actuelles miné au moins c'est
aussi quelque chose qu'il permet au
quotidien d'être plus dans le moment
présent et j'espère que peut-être pour
vous aussi grasset ou aux idéaux puisque
j'ai pu vous donner aujourd'hui dans
stoxx vous trouverez les moyens
d'améliorer votre performance ou la
pression mais aussi peut-être d'être
plus souvent dans le moment présent dans
la vie de tous les jours merci
[Applaudissements]